the idea that the Endangered Species Act
was responsive alligator recovery is a
myth there's no question about that
there's renewed uproar tonight over that
hunter who killed Cecil the lion
earlier this month Cecil was lured out
of the protected park with bait then he
was shot worldwide anger over his
illegal killing the internet went on an
outrage bender after a well-to-do
American dentist shot and killed
Zimbabwean icon Cecil the lion on a
trophy hunt he went into hiding for a
while
but when he returned to work a couple
months after the incident protestors
were still camped outside of his office
I see that man and I just want to slap
him he is just killing big beautiful
endangered animals is a cultural taboo
for most Americans but what if it's a
belief that does more harm than good
what if the truth were that when
governments legalized hunting and trade
of valuable animals and move it out of
the black market it actually helps
sustain their populations as it turns
out that's exactly what happened with
one iconic North American predator the
American alligator
I think alligators is a unique animal
because of the value of the skin and
meat and because it's a reptile as well
people are more accepting of us treating
them more like fish those people that
are most interested in the conservation
of alligators in many cases are those
who depend upon them for their
livelihood Allen Woodward and Tommy
Hinds ran the Florida Fish and Wildlife
Conservation Commission's alligator
conservation program
and were largely responsible for the
wildly successful management of the
state's alligator population a key
element of their strategy was a
willingness to work with hunters and
traders to save the alligator but it was
an approach that rubbed some
environmentalists the wrong way I kind
of separate preservation from
conservation preservation groups early
on won an all-out bat on alligator
hunting sometimes on humane grounds
sometimes on emotional ground they just
absolutely oppose harvest of wild
animals alligator hunting is now widely
practiced and accepted and even the
subject of reality TV shows like swamp
people but it wasn't always this way
for decades proponents of wildlife
preservation have touted the Endangered
Species Act as the savior of the
American alligator the story of the
American alligator is one of both
drastic decline and complete recovery
according to the US Fish and Wildlife
Service it is truly one of the prominent
successes of the nation's and dangered
species program the idea that the
Endangered Species Act was responsive
alligator recovery is a myth there's no
question about that Hinds points to his
own field experience and a number of
studies as evidence that the alligator
population was already stable and
growing by the time the federal
government listed it as endangered a
survey estimated Florida's alligator
population to be higher than 400,000 and
more than 700,000 nationwide the year
that the feds listed it as endangered a
majority of US counties reported stable
or increasing populations the best
population data comes out of Louisiana
which found a huge increase in nests
between 1970 and 1980 biologist Ted
jounin determined that a spike in such a
short amount of time
couldn't have been due to the 1973
Endangered Species Act since Gators take
a full 10 years to reach sexual maturity
in fact listing the alligator is
endangered may have actually hampered
Florida and Louisiana's efforts to
create a well regulated and monitored
market and trade because it prohibited
them
from setting reasonable hunting and
harvesting quotas the last Endangered
Species Act was somewhat problematic to
get alligators off the endangered
species list required a lot more
information than it did to put
alligators on we weren't able to get
them reclassified until 1977 and by that
time we were having major problems with
nuisance alligators in the state
it was another seven years to eight
years before we were able to get
alligators reclassified to threatens
dude assimilative appearance which
allowed us very broad in management
approaches to alligators which included
general harvest for recreation and
commercial if listing the alligator is
endangered wasn't the real reason for
its comeback what was Hines and Woodward
credits state-level management in the
60s and an amendment to the century-old
Lacey Act which created a legitimate
interstate market in alligator hides by
mandating that hides be tagged and
tracked by the states and it did so a
full four years before the passage of
the 1973 Endangered Species Act when the
government focused its efforts on
enabling a legitimate flexible market
the results were stunning landowners
suddenly had an incentive to maintain
alligator habitats in Florida about 40%
of alligator harvests happen on private
lands and in Louisiana
that number is closer to 90% the income
is derived from alligators provides us
somewhat of an incentive for private
landowners to maintain those wetlands
and those wetlands are used by a lot of
aquatic birds other aquatic wildlife
reptiles and amphibians and some mammals
as well so making something positive out
of the alligator also helps a broad
array of other wildlife as well our
alligator management and the research
budget is somewhere around 1.5 million
dollars the revenues we get from
alligators probably are somewhere around
2 million dollars that the state
actually gets while the alligator might
be unique in that it's both valuable and
less sympathetic than more cute and
furry animals Florida is just beginning
to grant licenses to hunt another a
large valuable animal the black bear and
it's already provoking emotional
backlash this is no more than a trophy
hunt just a way to get a new head on the
wall a rug on the floor or a poor as a
paperweight but if the American public
is willing to learn the lesson of the
alligator they might see that Commerce
and conservation are not enemies but
allies and that maybe sometimes you have
to hunt them to save them the whole
North American model of wildlife
management is based on the idea that
sustained harvest is not only possible
it's a positive because it generated a
tremendous amount of funds to go back
into conservation to come back into
wildlife research there was just a
recent controversy about Cecil maligned
and then I saw one just the last day or
two about the largest bull elephant that
had been taken in Zimbabwe for years the
truth of the matter is that big bull was
a problem no value to the elephant
population he was a much more value to
the country and to the people Zimbabwe
by letting that German hunter taking the
idea of applies over there in Africa
probably as much as it does anywhere in
the world